Okay.
I want to start with a,
with a question that was
asked by [inaudible] after
the last lecture regarding
fractional order kinetics.
Uh,
you remember that in the
reaction of methyl lithium,
there was a pre equilibrium between
the tetramer and the and the monomer.
So the tetramer is dominant,
but the monomer is reactive.
So remember what that meant was that
at an equal, in this pre equilibrium,
the rate of association equals
the rate of dissociation.
So the concentration of monomer to the
fourth power is proportional to that of
the tetramer. Or if you take the,
the fourth routes on each side,
it says that the concentration
of the, of the, uh,
reactive species is one fourth power in
the amount of material you actually add,
which is the dominant tetramer.
But why each,
what Aisha pointed out is this seemed
to be similar to the case of a radical
chain initiator, which also had
a fractional order. Remember,
the idea was that the initiator,
uh, breaks to give to radicals.
Then the radical abstracts a hydrogen to
give the radical, which is part of the,
uh, cycling mechanism in
the, in the radical chain.
The propagation steps of
the free radical reaction,
but ultimately that the machines are
destroyed by two radicals getting together
in the termination process,
either forming xx or x
with our or our with our,
so at first glance, this doesn't look very
similar to the equilibrium on the top.
This isn't an equilibrium at all,
right?
You're not going back to
the starting material,
you're not getting back to the
peroxide. So this one was, was uh,
uh, is an example of a steady
state instead of an equilibrium.
So when the machine gets,
when the,
the initiation is constantly going on,
the machine gets into a steady state
of how fast it's going around and
disappearing at the same time.
Then then you have the,
the amount of termination
equals the amount of initiation.
So you have a steady amount of this,
which is going to determine the
rate of the reaction of the machine.
And since the termination is proportional
to the concentration of radical
squared, it could be, it could be the
radical could be in the form either of x,
Adam or in the form of the are radical.
But whatever it is that when two
of them get together, that does it.
So the radicals concentration squared,
how much machine there is squared is
proportional to the, to the initiation,
to the concentration of
this. Okay. So this is,
this isn't an equilibrium as it was in
the top, but really it's the same deal.
The number of machines
then is proportional to the
square root of the amount of
the initiator.
Right?
And notice that this is
the same association equals
dissociation implies this
relationship. Termination equals
initiation implies this relationship.
So really they are the same thing. Even
though when she asked me the question,
I thought they were completely different.
So I've been teaching this for
45 years or something like that.
And it never occurred to me that these
fundamentally where the same thing,
the reason, the reason you have
this fractional order kinetics.
So this was a simplification
and generalization that
I Isha came up with and
that's what constitutes progress in
science is when instead of having to
memorize a zillion things,
you find out that they're all the
same and you just know that one.
So congratulations to Asia and keep
up the good work, all you people.
That's what makes it fun to teach you.
After x years of teaching this,
I'm still learning. Okay?
And I also ask questions.
So on the 2009 exam, I asked, uh, uh,
consider this chlorination reaction,
the one we talked about at the end
of last lecture and a certain Bond
Association energies. And then you're
supposed to figure out various things.
But part g of this many part,
a question was why should the bond
association energies of NCL and RCL be so
different when those of
Nh and rh are so similar?
So NCL is 46,
and h is 92,
twice as big a RCL and rh
are about the same energy.
Why is that?
Well,
what I expected the answer I expected it
was based on this lone pair repulsion.
So here on the left we have
peroxide and and ethane,
they have the same number of electrons,
right?
And on the right we
have NCL and methyl cl,
the same number of electrons on the right.
Okay?
Now if you look at the
Bond Association energies,
this one is twice as strong as that one.
And this one is nearly
twice as strong as that one.
So what makes the ones on the top so
weak when really it's the same number of
electrons involved up and down.
Okay,
well what you notice is that on top you
have lone pairs on the atoms that are
being bonded, which will
repel one another. So the,
the Idi expected was that that would
weaken the bond. Now is this plausible?
Could the electron repair
electron pair repulsion?
Explain the difference in Bond Association
energies between the top and bottom,
what we could look at,
how the electrons actually are arranged
as we calculate it by quantum mechanics.
And of course what it looks like depends
on what contour we draw this contour at
point double o two uh,
electrons per cubic bor radius
is not very informative.
But if we go in further to
higher densities to 0.01 to 0.05,
2.25,
now we see something different in
these two things you'd noticed.
That's what that, uh,
in the, in the bottom,
the protons that are out here,
the Proton on the carbon as opposed to
where there is no proton on the oxygen
draws these electrons out. Right.
And the same thing here, the,
the hydrogen that's pulled out of the
nitrogen nucleus and put out here to
become ch three that draws these
electrons out so that they don't repel one
another as much. So, uh, uh,
that seems a plausible explanation,
although it's not quantitative.
Okay. So we would say then that the
repulsion between the electrons,
which is less in the case
where they've been drawn out,
might be an important factor in,
in stabilizing the ones where
the electrons are drawn out.
That was the answer I
expected on the exam.
Cause we had talked about
lone pair repulsion, right.
So that seems a plausible
explanation for weakening.
Oh versus cc or NCL versus CCL.
But that wasn't the answer I got on a
lot of the, some people gave that answer,
but a lot of them appealed to then that
difference of electronegativity so that
CCL has a big difference in
electronegativity according
to the polling scale of
electronegativity.
So carbon has 2.55 chlorine 3.16
they're quite different in their
electronegativity whereas nitrogen
3.04 is rather similar to the 3.16.
So that was what people had in mind then
was there'd be an important resonance
structure for CCL. That would be c
plus cl minus. And that would be,
we know, we associate the existence of
resonance structures with stabilization.
Uh,
now we've seen that we can understand
that thing in terms of the,
the energies of orbitals that the
concept that was involved there. Uh,
we, we start with a, with a bond
either with nitrogen to chlorine,
which would have its electrons.
There are carbon to chlorine,
which would have its electrons down there.
And then if we're going to break the bond,
those electrons,
if we're going to go to ions like end
plus or c plus and cl minus these electron
pairs would have to go onto the chlorine
and they have to go farther when
they're on the nitrogen.
So that mismatch and energies aids
breaking them Hetero literally for the,
uh, for the carbon for case
where the carbon is mismatched,
you don't have to go up as much.
So it's easier to ionize,
but that's not what we're talking
about in bond association energy.
In Bond Association energy,
we're talking about breaking to two free
radicals where one goes on, one Adam,
one electron goes on the other from the
payer. And now as we talked about, uh,
early last semester in terms of bond
association energy or Homolysis,
it's the carbon chlorine bond is stronger,
right?
So this is putting a slightly
more quantitative stuff,
uh, ideas to bear on the
idea of why, uh, the,
you have that difference in bond strength,
but the idea of,
of electronegativity being associated
with bond strength is an interesting one
that's worth tracing down a little bit.
So I'm going to talk just a little bit
today about electronegativity and bond
strengths. Uh, the first
few, as I've mentioned this
last semester in English, uh,
of, uh, of, uh,
of the word electronegativity was in
1837 and systems of mineralogy by James
Dwight Dana.
And we mentioned that James Might,
Dana was a professor
here at Yale, uh, in the,
in the 19th century. Uh, he, uh,
lived in this House that, that, uh,
you've walked by and which is now
a national historical monument.
And he lived in the house with his wife,
Henrietta Dana.
Actually it was Henry at a Silliman.
Dana was her,
was her maiden name and she
was the daughter of Benjamin
Solomon whose statue is
just down past Nate out there on the,
as you see them on the way up I think is,
is a snow necklace has
gone this week. Okay. So,
uh, Dana was well married. Okay.
That's just to give you a
little local color on the bay,
but electronegativity in the sense
we use it. Uh, what, what, what puts,
what sense with Dana have been
involved in electronegativity in 1837,
what idea was going around that,
where the negativity or positivity
of Adams would be important?
Dualism, right? Right. The idea
of what held things together,
he thought if you could understand what
was negative and what was positive,
then you could understand
minerals in that case.
But electronegativity in the sense of
organic chemistry or Inorganic Chemistry
for that matter was popularized by Linus
Pauling beginning with this paper in,
uh, in, uh, 1933, uh,
or 1932, it was published. Okay?
So this is the key passage in that paper.
And remember that Pauling was
pushing this idea of resonance,
that you get stabilization when you can
draw different resonance structures.
So he's talking about the attitude of
the energies of normal covalent bonds.
He says there's empirical evidence in
support of the postulate that the energies
of normal covalent bonds are additive.
Now what does he mean by additive?
That is that if you have Adam's a and B,
you could have a,
you could have a baby and a
baby and you could have a B.
And his idea is that the bond strength
and a B should be the average of what you
have in Aa and what you have in BB.
So he was a little confusing about that
because in some papers he used this
concept using the arithmetic mean,
but in others he talked about
the geometric mean where
it was the square root of
the product instead of the half
the sum. Okay. But at any rate,
the idea was that normal covalent bonds
should be the average of the whole of
the homo nuclear bonds.
So he uses them this,
this plot where he's measuring
the energies of the bonds,
Bond Association, energies in
unusual units for us electron volts,
right? It's you multiply by 23 to
get kilocalories per mole. Okay.
So here are our HX bonds that are normal,
that that is calculated
if they were normal there.
The average of the HH and the xx for the
different halogens as you see fluorine,
chlorine, bromine, and
item. Okay. But the actual,
uh,
now,
incidentally there's a little problem
here because he was using the wrong value
for the fluorine, fluorine bond
energy, and all of this work.
He thought it was 65 kilocalories from
all. Actually it's 38. It's a very,
it's a rather weak bond because of all
these electron pair repulsions that we
talked about. Okay. So his
numbers are a little bit skewed,
but then he rate that was
what he was doing. But now,
so this is theoretical all
to get these red numbers.
He used hh and x ax and just
took their average. Okay.
Now observed values are this,
the bonds are actually
stronger than you expect,
but they're not all stronger
by the same amount, right?
So you can look in Paul,
and the reason is in Pauling's theory,
this residence theory that you can
have the polar resonance structure,
which makes it more
stable and now you can,
what this suggests is that there's this
difference Delta between what you would
expect if it were normal, the
average, and what you observed,
which is what you have when you
have this polar resonance structure.
And what he says here, the greater
the ionic character of the bond,
the greater will be the value of Delta.
Okay?
So the need idea now
is we could use delta,
which is x based on experimental numbers
as a way to measure how important
resonance is,
right?
So you could measure resonance
stabilization by Delta if you follow,
if you adopt his assumptions that
normal bonds are the average,
right? And now you've measure these
and then you get the difference,
tells you how important
resonance stabilization is.
And then you try to see if
there's something you can
correlate to predict how,
how important resonance
stabilization should be. All right?
So he has this rather complicated
table two in the paper,
which has observed bond energies,
normal bond energies,
Delta and the square root of Delta.
Okay?
Now let's show how that works by
taking one particular block here.
So we're comparing oxygen and fluorine,
okay?
So here on the table we look at oxygen,
oxygen, and it's Bond Association.
Energy is 1.49 electron volts,
okay?
Or you can look over here and fluorine.
Fluorine is 2.8 so if
the bond were normal,
the oxygen fluorine bond would be the
average of those, right? Which is,
although remember actually this is 1.65
it's not 2.8 but put that aside for now.
Okay. Now then, if you look
at oxygen with fluorine,
the Bond Association energy observed
as 2.48 now we can compare that,
uh,
it's,
notice it's not the average
of 1.49 and 2.8 it's too high,
right? So we could calculate
what the normal would be,
what the average is of o and f,
F and then we can take the difference.
The difference is 0.33 that's delta.
That's how much in his view,
the,
the olf bond has been stabilized
because of the resonance structure.
Okay? Now, is there a way to predict
how big that Delta should be?
Well, here's the same deal
with carbon and fluorine.
And notice that the Delta for carbon
and fluorine is 2.2 much bigger than
between oxygen and fluorine,
which was only 0.33 or you could look
in a different block and see what it is
for carbon and oxygen.
It's 1.0 so we know carbon to oxygen,
how much it is,
we know carbon to flury
and how much it is.
And we know oxygen to flury how big it is.
Is there some relationship among these
that we could have? Knowing two of them,
we could have predicted the third,
well not really because the difference
between CNF and the difference minus the
difference between CNO is not the
difference between ONF. It doesn't work.
You can't add up the polarity
differences that way.
But then he tried something else.
He tried taking the square root of Delta.
That's the brown numbers here.
So this is the square root
of those stabilizations.
And now you see something interesting
that the difference between c,
uh,
between CEO and CF is the
difference between o and F.
Pretty close,
right?
So it's about the square
roots are about additive. Now,
I don't think he had any good reason to
theoretically say say it should be the
square root, but he fiddled with the
numbers that he noticed that worked.
So the question is, does it work
for all the elements? If so,
then from something you can
predict the others. Okay,
so here he has the here's he has those,
the square roots of Delta for
carbon versus other things. That is,
how important is the resonance structure,
the square root of the
stabilization of the bond. How?
How important is that for ch four CN,
for CEO, for CF, for CECL, for CBR.
And can we use that to establish a scale
of how different the polarities are
among those different atoms?
Okay,
so here he has carbon and
here's hydrogen on one side,
then bromine, chlorine and
nitrogen, oxygen and fluorine.
On the other side,
the distances,
there are those numbers we
just saw on the previous slide.
How important in after taking the
square root is that energy difference?
That stabilization. Okay, so
he did it with carbon. Now,
Eh, so you get some values. But
if those values are fundamental,
then you should get the same scale.
No matter what Adam you use.
You don't have to do carbon acts.
You could do nitrogen x or oxygen x or
anything else acts and you should always
get the same scale if the
system is going to work.
So that's these other horizontal lines.
Noticed that in the case of carbon,
the difference between carbon and oxygen
is one the difference between carbon
and fluorine is 1.48 and
then the difference between
oxygen and fluorine is 0.48
and experimentally, if you measure
relative to oxygen, oxygen to flu,
Rita's 0.58 not bad.
Okay,
so here are the others compared
to oxygen for the o x bonds.
And here they are relative to hydrogen,
right?
And notice that as you come down with
oxygen, fluorine, chlorine, nitrogen,
bromine, carbon, they're
sort of the same, right?
It's the same order and
they're about the same.
So this isn't the last word in theory,
but it looks like something
pretty fundamental.
And then here he used relative to
both h on one end and f on the other.
So he called these things
the scale electronegativity.
And here he gives the
increasing electronegativity,
which is just those numbers,
the square root of the stabilization of
the bond right from the previous slide.
And here are the values for hydrogen,
phosphorus, iron and sulfur,
carbon and so on.
And these were the days when they still
did handwritten figures in the Journal
of the American Chemical Society,
which was a long time ago. Okay.
And then below that he looks at,
it's Matt,
I couldn't figure out for a long
time what the heck this was.
But finally I figured out, he
doesn't say in the paper, but
it's a picture of the periodic table,
which has been distorted so that
it shows every atom at its proper
electronegativity. So here
are the halogens here, the
cow Kaja, nides, nitrogen,
phosphorous, carbon and
so on. In other words,
he's taken the periodic table and he's
distorted that like that so that the
numbers go from red to yellow as
you go from left to right. Okay.
So that's where electronegativity
and the current sense,
the Pauling scale of electro negativity,
that's where it came from.
Okay.
And notice that what it really depends
on is what the periodic table depends on
is that as you go across here,
you have how the nuclear charge is
increasing the screened nuclear charge.
We talked about that last semester.
And as you go down,
the number of nodes in the
valence shell is increasing.
That's what gives the
periodic table it's character.
That's what explains electronegativity.
Okay.
So the idea of this was to push the
idea of the, the concept of resonance.
Now is it surprising that we find that
bond strength correlates with differences
in Pauline's electro negativities?
Remember that's how the Chi sub P is
Pauline's electronegativity values.
Remember how we got into this question?
We said,
why are these polar bonds like
NCL unusually weak compared to,
to uh, to, uh, to, to bonds
that don't have that difference
in electro negativity.
And we said it was
repulsion of electron pairs,
but some people said it's
electronegativity. Now I asked you,
is it surprising here that bond
strength correlates with Pauling's
electronegativity scale?
Does anybody got a,
you have an opinion on
that after what I had been saying,
I've gone through this pretty fast,
so I don't expect expect you to,
but I was impressed by the question
I got after the last lecture,
so I thought I'd give it a try here.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
because that's where the electro
negativities came from in Pawling.
He used the bond there member, it's
the square root of the, of the,
of the bond strength stabilization that
he used to get the electronegativity
scale. So it's not
surprising at all, Nate.
You're exactly right that the appalling
electronegativity scale was defined by
the differences and bond strengths
from the averages. Now, uh,
in the first issue of nature
of this week, this, this year,
this year has been proclaimed the
international year of chemistry.
So you're sitting in the right class here.
Uh,
so the first issue of nature
was celebrating chemistry
and they had a bunch of
essays and one of them,
uh,
on pages 26 to 28 was by Phillip Ball
and it was called beyond the bond.
Have we gone moved beyond bonds now?
Can we just use quantum mechanics
to talk about things? I remember,
this was the question we asked at the
end of last semester, right? If Bond,
if the history of chemistry hadn't
developed the way it did in terms of bonds
and we just had quantum mechanics with
anybody ever have talked about bonds,
if you could just calculate
all these numbers and the,
a little squib about this,
uh,
about this article said
more than ever before,
new techniques show the bond
to be a convenient fiction,
albeit one that holds the field of
chemistry together, finds Phillip Ball.
But one passage in that I
thought was particularly timely,
he said by the 1960s for all Pauling's
salesmanship ammo theory was generally
agreed to be more convenient than his
resonance theory for most purposes.
So when I was a student,
resonance theory was a really big thing
and molecular orbital theory was just
coming on. But it's
really different now. Now,
molecular orbital theory is
what people mostly focus on.
And only certain communities tend
to talk about resonance, but, but,
uh,
but elementary teaching tends
to lag behind where people are.
So resonance is still a big thing
in AP courses, I suspect, and so on.
But at any rate,
it's not surprising really,
that it certainly is not surprising
that it should correlate with Pauling's
scale because that's what
he used to define it. Bond
strengths. But the idea of,
of of polar bonds being,
having high bond association energy in
terms of what we've talked about first,
how far the electrons have to go up
when you break the bond to get two free
radicals, that's it. We expect
that the energy mismatch,
we'll strengthen bonds.
So accrued correlation of appalling
electronegativity scale plotted vertically
with other measures of how tightly
electrons are held. The orbital event,
orbital energy,
for example,
how much energy it takes to pull
an electron away from an Adam,
or how much energy,
uh, do you, uh, do you,
does it take to pull an electron
away from a charged ion? Right.
Both of those things are our
measures of, of orbital energy. Uh,
and that's what's called
Mulligan's electronegativity scale,
which he published two
years later in 1934,
the average of ionization potential,
an electron affinity. So this,
this one,
Mulligan was the,
was the one of the chief originators
of molecular orbital theory,
which in the middle of the
century was in real competition.
It was like a little bit like a radical
theory and type theory 100 years
earlier, right? There was a lot
of competition between them, but,
but mulligans theory,
which has to do with orbital energy,
we can understand and we
see that it correlates more
or less well with Pauline's
electronegativity scale.
So fine.
So electronegativity does
have something to do with it,
but electronegativity really is
not sort of a fundamental property.
It was measured in terms of
these bond stabilizations. Okay.
That's a little bit of a,
of a sidelight to what we're
actually talking about.
The Chemistry and physics
of Al Keel Haylight is,
we're going to talk about now a free
radical halogenation introduces a
functional group into alkanes normal
alkanes don't have a functional group,
a unusually high homo or low Lumo.
Once you've done a free
radical reaction on those,
now you have this unusually
low Lumo sigma star.
So you can be in doing things with it.
So what we're going to talk about now
having talked about free radical reactions
is the ionic chemistry
involving that Sigma Star.
So we're going to talk
about the alcohol Halides,
which now we know how to prepare.
So these are nuclear affiliate
substitution and acidity
is much the same thing.
We mentioned this preliminarily
last semester, uh,
that so there are non bonded
interactions and salvation,
which is key for ionic reactions.
And I just noticed that all the
work I did since last night is uh,
is not in here cause I've redone
that slide. Uh, so the question is,
am I going to put that in here or not?
It would take about two seconds.
Well it'll take about a minute to break
here and start again with the most
recent version,
which I can't,
I can't sacrifice all the
work I did since last night.
I stayed up late so
I'm going to save this,
uh,
pardon me.
Does by the steak this morning I loaded
the PR, the version that was on the web.
Okay.
I've got that saved now nearly.
Oh, it's saving it over the
web. That's the problem.
I hadn't reckoned on that one.
Are there any questions
while we're pausing for this?
Yeah,
it just incidentally,
how much did you learn about
electronegativity in high school?
Was this a big focus of your AP course?
Yeah.
So now you know where it came from,
came from Dana down the
hill and then Pauling. Okay,
there we go.
Now.
Yeah.
Let's see. I want the other
version that's here, I think.
Yeah.
And here we are.
So I'm going to do that last slide again
cause that's where I noticed things
were bad. Uh, so free radical halogenation
introduces a functional group,
uh, and we're gonna now be
looking at that functional group,
that chemical and physical
properties of alcohol. Hey Lights,
which involves sigma star, the functional
group we've been able to put in.
So we have sn one reactions in which
those electrons go on to x in order to
break the bond.
And we have those in which the
new electrons have gone into,
into sigma star in order
to help the x leave.
And that's the sn two reaction.
And if the Adam in the
middle is h instead of our,
then this same thing as acidity,
right?
So that's why we introduced
this concept last semester.
But we're going to talk about it in more
detail in terms of reaction mechanisms
now, okay. Now in the process,
this makes uh,
uh,
this makes ions right?
So we have to go beyond the molecules
themselves and thinking about this
reaction because non bonded interactions
and salvation turns out to be key for
ionic reactions. You can't just
look at the reacting species.
You have to look at the surroundings,
which makes everything ever so
much more complicated. Okay.
Now this is Henri
Victorville and you'll uh,
who lived as you see in the middle
of the 19th century and you know,
is that a lot,
the first letter of his last name because
it said that that's where they are,
comes from. It stands for renewal because
he did a lot of thermodynamics stuff.
This, Oh, PV equals NRT is this
man. Now in 1850 he wrote a book,
the first elements of chemistry,
and there's one passage about chemical
affinity here that I think is worth
looking at. He says, for
chemical affinity to act freely,
substances must be dispersed.
Now this was of course writing an 1850
this was before bonds or anything,
but they knew you don't
just mix solids together,
you have to disperse them and
you can't just grind them right?
Since dispersion by mechanical
pulverization is incomplete,
the molecules have to touch molecules,
not just particles of stuff,
touch particles, right? They must be
taken into the liquid or gaseous state.
Previous chemists expressed this fact
by saying corporate known arduous Niecy.
So Luta substances do not
react unless they're dissolved.
So this very,
this dissolution,
the fact of what's around the things
is what's going to be important and
understanding reactions.
So the theory of organic chemistry
became manageable in the first place when
people started studying gases,
as you remember,
because it's often possible to focus on
a simple unit with strong interactions.
That's molecules or the individual
and bonds within them or the strong
interactions with well-defined geometries
and energies as we discussed last
semester.
And you neglect the much more numerous
and complex intermolecular interactions
with the solvent.
Right?
But actually we are going
to have to consider those
because we're interested not
just in the gas phase but in solution.
So it was essential to go into the gas
phase in order to get a toe hold on
understanding chemistry
in the first place.
But if you want to understand
real practical chemistry,
you have to understand solutions.
So these weak intermolecular
interactions give organic materials,
many of their most valuable properties.
Most of the properties of
what's important in your,
in your bodies are not things that
involve making and breaking bonds,
but changing non bonded
interactions between things.
And that's what we're going to be
looking at for a little while now.
So non bonded classical energies.
Okay,
now suppose you have a uh,
just cool ohms law charge,
charge interaction.
That's where we started last semester.
That's as you know,
the only true source of
chemical potential energy. Uh,
there's gravity and physics and magnetism.
But those are, those are tiny, right?
They're nothing compared to cool ohms law.
There's the strong force
that's for physicist,
that's way above what we
deal with in chemistry.
The cool ohms law is where we live,
right?
That it's proportional
to one over R as we know.
And the constant for the proportionality
is minus 300 332 kilocalories per mole.
When you,
when you use angst from units.
So this provides a very long range
attraction, right? Even when you're,
when you're three angst drums apart,
the energy is still a hundred
kilocalories per mole, right?
Actually now where should
we start with zero?
We could start with zero when they're
infinitely far away and then we use cool
ohms law to get the energy,
how the energy goes down,
or if we're thinking of breaking the bond,
we could start at the bond distance and
then stress or the distance between two
ions and see how much it takes to pull
them apart a certain distance, right?
So if we start a bond is one and a half,
let's take bigger ions.
Let's suppose there
are two Ostrom's apart.
That means they're at a 332 over
to the energy is minus 165 okay.
If we go to three on extremes,
then it's minus 100 so we've gone up
and energy by about 100 kilocalories per
mole in going from two to three Ostrom's
and we have a lot further to go on the
way out.
This is very different from covalent
bonds where when you get to three Ostrom,
that's the end of the line.
So covalent bonds are typically
a hundred kilocalories per mole,
but you get there very quickly,
so they're very stiff, right?
You break the bond, you,
you, as you break the bond,
you go up and energy really quickly.
Who loan doesn't go up as rapidly,
but it goes up very,
very far.
So it's long range and that's why solve
this are so important because they saw
another molecule can be rather far
away and still influence ions where it
wouldn't influence free
radicals. Okay? So,
uh, eh, but this is media.
This is a attenuated by a solvent.
If you have a dielectric constant,
as it's called in the solvent,
that reduces the magnitude of,
of the, uh, Coolum big energy
or the Coolum Vic forests. Now,
how big are these values
of, of, uh, epsilon?
Right? Here's some values taken
from the, from the Jones book, uh,
noticed that hexane is a factor of two.
So that'll take things from that.
Take that constant from 300
down to one 50, still quite big.
But if you go to something
like water at 78,
that cuts it way down,
right? This is about,
this is about this, into,
this is something like four,
right?
So it's only four kilocalories per mole
rather than 332 kilocalories per mole.
If you're operating in water with
water all around the islands, right?
So that makes an enormous difference
how these ions are going to interact,
what solvent you're in,
and it makes quite a difference.
What solvent and notice down to acetone,
the solvents might be considered polar.
That is,
they have pretty big dielectric constants.
So they really attenuate the energy
of interaction between the ions.
But chloroform,
ether hexane or not very polar,
they don't cut it down very much.
Now this has to do with things like the
solubility or the melting point of salts
like sodium chloride or uh,
or Tetra methyl ammonium iodide.
Because notice that these
ions are rather small,
so the charges are close together,
but these ions are big so they're
substantially further apart.
And that's going to make an enormous
difference in when you're starting to pull
them apart, right? If you, if you
go to twice the distance here,
right? You really cut
this way down so that, uh,
so that cesium,
cesium iodide,
sodium chloride has a melting point
of something like 801 Celsius.
But cesium iodide,
the same charges,
but bigger ions is 200 degrees lower and
it's melting point and the solubilities
reflect the same thing.
It's easier to get the solids apart
if you're starting with bigger ions.
Okay? So the big interaction
is charged, charged,
but there are others that are
important to charge with dipole.
So if you have a molecule
that's not charged but has
a dissymmetry in the charge,
that's within it.
So it has a plus and a minus in,
then those can interact and
that's proportional to one
over r squared so it dies
away more rapidly.
Right.
And if the dipole can orient so that
you have to average over different ways,
it could be oriented,
it would be oriented more likely in the
favorable than in the unfavorable way.
But that depends on the temperature
and if you have that situation,
it turns out to be our to the minus forth
over temperature because of how much
is favored one way or the other.
Okay.
Then if you go to uh,
charged with something that's non polar
but could become polar if it's put in
the field of another charge.
So you put the push the nucleus one way,
the electrons the other way and now you
get a charge interacting with an induced
dipole that that depends on our to
the minus three one over r cubed.
Then you can have two dipoles
interacting with one another.
That's also one over r cubed or you can
have to induce things interacting with
one another. Have you ever
seen that before? Where the,
how the electrons are distributed
in this one, when they're over here,
the ones here tend to be over there.
And when these are here, these are here.
Where did we encounter that before?
Yeah.
Correlation energies.
Right? Okay. So, uh, that,
that turns out to be our to the sixth
power. So notice that these others,
other than the Coolo,
they fall off very,
very rapidly and they
start very weak, right? So,
so there you might think
you could neglect them,
but there could be a lot of them.
That's the problem when there are
many solvent molecules around. Okay.
Now let's look at some trends in the
highlights and whatever textbook you have,
you'll find this guy did the, when we
talk about different functional groups,
we're talking about the alcohol haylight
now typically chapters in all the books
you look at.
We'll start with something about the
physical properties of those compounds and
then go onto their chemical properties.
So this is a little bit about physical
properties of the highlights. So, uh,
here we look at the van der walls,
radius of the Halogen X.
Right?
And here we look at the bond
distance between x and carbon.
And you notice they're
almost exactly the same.
And we learned something from that,
which is that non bonded distances or
something like twice bonded distances,
right?
Because the rate,
the radius of an atom is about the same
as the distance from the nucleus of the
atom is the nucleus of
the carbon, right? So the,
so that means that the, that the
covalent radius is about half the, uh,
the van der walls radius.
Okay. Now here's the property,
the dipole moment, right? How,
how polar is the molecule,
right? And it's the, the dipole moment
shown here.
What do you notice about that as you
go fluorine and chlorine and bromine?
Iodine.
What's the first thing you do
notice about the trend
doesn't work for age,
Derek with h? Uh, well I
didn't put it, if you have age,
it turns out there is no dipole
moment because it's with methyl.
So h c h three is a symmetrical molecule
in the center of the electrons is the
same as the center of
the Nuclei. So, but what,
here's one. The red is a
trend as you go, well forget,
forget hydrogen because it's, it's
not really a halogen. But here,
here's radios, the d, The bond distance.
What's special about this one? About
the yellow, the orange one, Lauren.
Pardon me? It goes up and
down. It's not monotonic.
What do you learn when you see
trends that are not monotonic?
There must be two things
going on. So what's the other
thing here? We're interest
in the Po in how much charge is separated?
Here we have a ch three and a halogen.
So the dipole moment is
how big the charges are and
how much they're separated.
Right now we already see here
That is what the distance is.
But how big is the charge? Right?
So if we look here, this is
incidentally majored in Dubai units,
which if you multiply by a,
which is 4.8 times the
charge times the separation,
now we know the separation.
Uh,
and we noticed that it's not
monotonic and here's the charge.
How many electrons have been transferred,
right? And that's quite monotonic,
right?
But what we've seen here is that the
dipole moment is the product of two
properties. How much charge
and how much separated, right?
But they're opposing trends.
As one goes up,
the other goes down and
although they're both monotonic,
one is nonlinear,
more nonlinear than the other,
so they don't exactly cancel one another
and going up and down and you get weird
behavior. This, this, uh,
this when you have conflicting
nonlinear trends. Okay,
so there were two things going on to
give the dipole moment. Now the other,
you can see similar kinds of thing in
another measure of the size of atoms,
which is so called a value.
That's how much is axial compared
to Ecuadorian in cyclohexane?
Axial is more crowded than Ecuadorian is.
We talked about this last semester.
So if we know how much is it,
what the energy differences
between axial and equatorial,
we have some measure of how
big that group is. All right?
So it's the axial minus energy
equatorial in kilocalories from also that
measures size.
Now here are the values for the
halogens and hydrogen, incidentally,
which is defined as zero because you're
comparing hydrogen with hydrogen.
Okay, so here it is, and again,
you see it's not monotonic,
it goes up and down.
So there must be two things involved.
What are the two things? One of the
things is how big the Vanderwall is,
radius of the atom is, which clearly gets
bigger as you go. Flooring, chlorine,
bromine, iodine. But why does this,
why does the effect on axial
versus equatorial? Go up and down.
Why doesn't it just go up?
The bond?
This is between the carbon
and the substituent. Ah,
because the bond gets longer
as the Adam gets bigger, right?
So it's not not a tonic that suggests
there's a competition. So here's fluorine.
That's what's shown here.
And now watch this model is I
changed from fluorine to iodine.
And what happened? The Adam
gets bigger, not shown to scale,
but the bond gets longer,
right?
So you have a larger Vander walls radius,
but it stands off further.
So it's not so dramatic.
The difference.
Now compare that with what if
the group there is ch three,
right? Because ch three has, has this,
uh,
effective Vander walls radius.
So that's how I decided where
to put it on this scale, right?
It's got the right Vanderwalt radius,
but the bond distance for carbon carbon
is much shorter than it is for bromine
and iodine or chlorine for that. Or it's
about, it's about the same as fluorine,
right? Or a little bit bigger. Okay. And
now when we put these two things together,
in order to get the a value there,
there's,
we got this big group and it's come
in some compared to the halogens.
Now you see there's a really wild
outlier in this thing because of the,
because you now have a big group
to ch three and it's short.
So it, so even though, even
though the radius of, of, of, uh,
of methyl is about,
is about between bromine denied in its
effect on this as much bigger because it
sits in closer.
Okay?
Now the boiling points of the [inaudible],
here's a table.
We could have taken it from any book.
This particular one is from the Jones
tax that chose different al kill groups
and the hydrogen fluorine,
chlorine, bromine. I'd and
what are the boiling points?
Now,
let's just see if we can understand this.
I'm going to go just a little
bit further because we had that.
We started late with people getting here
late and we had that little break in
the class. Okay, so let's look
at the boiling points. So high,
so methane,
methane,
the one with hydro methyl with hydrogen
is very low boiling and then it gets
higher and higher and higher. That is
the liquid tends to hold together more.
Not to go into the gas phase. The
molecules are holding together more. Now,
the question is why? Why when we replace
hydrogen by fluorine, by chlorine,
by bromine,
by Ayah than does the boiling point Yo up?
What causes the molecules
to hold together?
It's not covalent bonds.
We're talking about non bonding
interactions. What is it? That whole,
what could make them altogether?
We know the fundamental forces.
That's what we just,
it's cool.
It was law as colored by
dipoles and things like that.
They are here tiresome.
Taco hydrogen,
hydrogen bonds as an idea now that you're
not going to get hydrogen bonds when
you don't have hydro
region,
right?
So the halogens I stuck on to work for,
and the next thing we're going to talk
about is hydrogen bonds that that'll come
in the next class. Now, any other ideas
of what holds them together? Date,
I even have polar interactions,
right? So you'd have dipoles slid,
interacting even though
there are no charges. Okay?
So let's look at the dipole moment,
which was on that previous table
and you see that methane has zero,
but fluorine has 1.85 so that's going
to allow the molecules to hold together,
okay? So raise the boiling point because
you could have them lined up this way,
right? But that's not just polarity
because if we go across here,
the polarity went up,
but then it goes down again.
But the boiling point keeps going up.
So there must be something else other
than that these dipoles holding together.
And that other thing is polarizability
how easy it is to shift the electrons in
the molecule and how many electrons
there are to shift. So you see,
if you look at fluorine,
chlorine, bromine,
and I had an Adams rite fluid.
Adam is very not non polarizable.
When you bring a charge
or a dipole near it,
it doesn't distort very much,
but chlorine distorts more bromine.
And I had in the most, because it has
the most electrons, the most weakly held,
right.
Or if we and ch four is not polar.
And also it's not very
polarizable. Right. Uh,
the hydrocarbon is,
is not very polarizable given that it's
five Adams of these are just one atom.
So, uh, next time we'll start,
we'll start at this point and go in to
try to understand the boiling point of
the alkanes without the halogen on them.
Thanks for Europe patients with
changing horses in midstream.